I thought it's fantastic to see you here
at London Film on comic-con winter today
we've enjoyed seeing you so much on
screen and Game of Thrones now that
fight was quite gruesome that you film
with Pedro fresca wasn't it tell us a
little bit about filming it behind the
scenes thank you it was a wonderful
experience for me it was a I was so
lucky to get this it's a great actor to
act against the Pedro Pedro Pascal is a
really talented and we came really good
together and and I think the reason why
the fight went so well because
we connected really well and and and and
the fight went as good as as possible I
think it looks fantastic on screen
speaking of which what did you feel what
was your reaction when you saw that
fight that you'd work so hard to bring
to life on screen I was to be honest I
don't like to watch myself on the screen
but when I saw the fight I thought it
was good it was very very good now
talking about fighting people are very
keen to see you finally fight your
brother the hand because in the first
season of the show there's about to be a
father fight with your brother the
hounds and then it's broken up so how
much would you like to fight the Hound
and who do you think would win
well if I'll be in next season or the
season of that or after that I don't
know you have to ask tentative but yes
if I will
I would like to fight him do you think
of course me you're too big and too
strong yes exactly
you